awesome thank you so much Michael this
is a really great pleasure and privilege
to be here I didn't realize it was your
first day of class this is really
exciting to get to be the first one to
chat with you all so what I'll be
talking about today is the work I'm
doing in the HCI Institute at Carnegie
Mellon on designing culturally relevant
educational technology at a global scale
but before I dive into that topic I just
wanted to tell you a little bit about
the broader context of the types of
things we do in learning Sciences in HCI
so some example projects I'm going to
show you so here's one on
personalization this is what most people
think about when they think about AI or
technology and education and it's the
ability to deliver the right content to
the right learner at the right time at
the right pace by knowing all about the
learner and what we should deliver them
so we have a lot of projects that work
on personalization we also have a bunch
of projects that then move on to adding
a face onto that personalized learning
environment so we build a lot of virtual
agents here what you see is a teachable
agent so it's actually a virtual learner
that the child gets to teach these
mathematical concepts so this is one of
the the applications that we have and we
show that building rapport between the
learner and the virtual agent actually
significantly impacts the learning
outcomes that students receive sometimes
we move on from a virtual faith and
actually put an embodied face on the
educational technology so here's the
project that we're just starting with
the Cosmo robot where it actually
engages learners with facial expressions
with its voice and really builds rapport
and a strength of relationship with the
learner in order to facilitate them
learning very difficult concepts in
programming so in this one we're working
with the Girl Scouts of America so I'm
super excited about that
and then the whole way up to doing
something like putting sensors in the
classroom and understanding the
positioning the behavior of learners and
also actually of the instructor as some
of you might recognize this instructor
Chris Harrison who's also the HD Island
Institute we can present instructors for
instance with where their gazes looking
throughout the majority of class so one
learning science principle is that I
should be walking around looking at all
of you engaging you in my talk and this
causes a not only a better engagement
from the students point of view but also
greater learning as well so these are
all things we can do to provide feedback
to the instructor on how they're doing
in their classroom so this is just a
super broad overview of all of the
different types of things that are
happening in my lab but today I wanted
to talk to you about the fact that we're
in the midst of an education
breakthrough around the world and so you
can see here from this chart an image of
the reduction in out-of-school children
across the world this is between 2000
and 2013 and now we're down even lower
millions and millions and millions of
new children are being introduced to
schooling and this is happening all
around the world you can see some of the
greatest reductions are in across Africa
and in South and Southeast Asia so this
is really exciting we finally have the
opportunity to reach a generation of
learners around the world who were never
previously exposed to literacy to
mathematics and to enable them a better
future through education yes
yes so there's a lot of infrastructure
infrastructure Elena's there's a
recognition that money money and
investment needs to be placed into
education there is a lot of
philanthropic efforts going on right now
but also some of its coming from places
like the World Bank so more and more
schools are being built more
infrastructures being developed that
allows those to be built roads road
networks cell networks all of those
things are contributing to being able to
actually get get people in just
physically into schools so getting them
physically in this school is one thing
but we at the same time have a learning
crisis on our hands so if you look at
this chart of high-income countries we
have a hundred and ninety-eight mill
million school-aged children in those
countries 70% of them will come out of
school learning minimum secondary level
skills a full eight percent of them will
come out without even having learned
basic basic primary level skills of
literacy and numeracy now that's in
high-income countries if we look at
middle-income countries the picture
looks a bit worse we have a thousand one
hundred and forty two million school-age
children there and almost 27 percent of
them will come out without learning any
basic level skills and if we look
further at low-income countries we see
almost a mirror image of what's
happening in high-income countries where
almost 70% of our learners come out
without having learned basic primary
level skills and this is despite the
fact that over half of these children
will have had more than four years of
schooling so they're in the school
buildings but the learning isn't
happening so this is our learning crisis
that we're working on solving often
through the use of technology so this is
a one of the major solutions that's
being proposed now is to distribute
technology to schools and the learning
will happen one-to-one computing devices
that are intended to engage learners to
provide them with the support they need
and to see those learning outcomes
happen now of course we've got had these
solutions in mind it's been almost 15
years now
since some of the earliest project
started distributing laptops in schools
with the hope of changing learners
abilities we've spent almost a billion
dollars of low-income countries money in
order to make this happen
and there's been almost no results on
learning games from these technologies
and yet why am I doing this we know that
there are really positive outcomes from
the use of technologies so here are just
some a set from Carnegie Mellon students
in second through fourth grade gained
three times as much in reading fluency
when they use an adaptive system called
Project listen compared to typical
reading practice are socially adaptive
robots produced 30% more math learning
for middle school students the non
adaptive robots peer tutors gives
significantly better help when they are
supported by artificial intelligence and
on and on and on so so we know that
there are positive impacts from
technology and this is even happening in
Africa as well so there's a great
meta-analysis called identifying
effective education interventions in
sub-saharan Africa and it found that of
all of the types of interventions that
have been rigorously evaluated in
sub-saharan Africa including providing
kids with school fees reducing the class
size giving them school supplies like
paper and pencil the ones that have
shown
the most impact are the distribution of
adaptive technology assisted learning
and pedagogical changes okay so now we
know that adaptive systems right ones
that actually provide the right support
to the learner those are the the
solutions that we can count on for
Africa so we're done all right yeah all
right not quite
unfortunately there is also a major
imbalance in the distribution of
education research and EdTech research
around the world so we looked at meta
analyses across a number of journals and
conferences that are related to
education or EdTech Journal of
Educational Psychology learning sciences
artificial intelligence and education
learning at scale 975 to 93 percent
across those different venues the
children the learners in their studies
are weird what do we mean by weird has
anybody heard this term before yeah okay
good great so they are Western educated
industrialized rich and developed
nations that are participating in this
work right this despite the fact that we
know that low-income countries are the
ones that need the vast majority of our
support we also know so this term comes
from Henrik at all looking at psychology
results across a wide number of
psychology topics and they have found
that psychology insights that we thought
applied to everybody in the world
actually often do not hold true in these
non-weird cultures well why is that
maybe because we are only studying a
very specific small set of the
population of the world and then
publishing these results as if they
apply to everyone all right and so many
studies have shown is that what this
leads to only only
working on this small population of the
world and then trying to introduce these
technologies or pedagogy's into the rest
of the world leads to boredom lack of
motivation difficulty in comprehending
the material and in fact often even
times staff leaving schools because they
feel so frustrated that the types of
things they're being asked to do don't
apply to their own classrooms so we know
this is a major major problem we know
the education is a major problem and we
know that we haven't found the way to
solve it yet I however have been very
fortunate enough to participate in
research across a wide set of sites
field sites across a wide slope swath of
the globe and in so doing in sitting in
classrooms in working with learners
there in introducing a set of
technologies we've been able to learn
quite a lot with the belief that AI in
education can actually work for
everybody around the world if we design
it - all right so I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about some principles that
we've learned as we've worked across a
variety of sites and I'm going to in
particular talk about some work
combining principles that we've learned
in studies being run in Latin America in
particular this is a some work in Costa
Rica
here's a sample image from a project
that I'm doing in Tanzania with tablet
based learning this one happens to be
sponsored by the XPrize Foundation we're
one of five finalists the only academic
team still in this competition we're
competing for a ten million dollar prize
if for the team that in increase is
learning the most and we'll find out on
May 15th so everybody keep your fingers
crossed for me
[Laughter]
thirdly work we're doing in the cote
d'ivoire the Ivory Coast with learners
learning literacy over the cellphone and
the general approach that we take on all
of this work is one called design based
research this comes out of the learning
sciences literature but it highly
applies to HCI in general so in this
approach we focus our problem set we
work on understanding the context and
the domain we define the types of things
we're doing basting on that
understanding we're designing and
developing new solutions and building
them and then we go out and test them
and that all looks on the surface like a
linear process but actually involves a
whole lot of looping back and forth and
multiple iterations of defining
conceiving building and testing things
and maybe even going back to reenter
stand the situation in the field so
that's the general process we've taken
for all of this and here is what we've
learned from doing that principle number
one is the importance of context
sensitive design so the first thing you
might think about when you think about
putting a technology in a new place is
the need for translation so obviously if
your learner speaks Spanish you can't
present them with an interface and
English like basic 101 we need to get it
in the right language one of the
interesting things that happens though
is it turns out it's not just language
we worked with folks who thought that
mathematics for instance is a universal
language everybody understands math math
works the same in every place and
actually it turns out that it it almost
does but not quite so for instance
here's an example of how long division
is often done in
this was described by a norwegian
student living in america as something
strange to her
it says no one is using this algorithm
in Norway anymore
so you can see the eighths on the left
and then you have this little house sort
of thing
in steam you actually the same
mathematics problem is done in Reverse
right the 8th is now on the right hand
side and you have the little division
symbol in between them so a very
different approach to this and then even
within a country so we looked at Spain
and then in Catalunya right completely
different from everything else now we
turn our house upside down and and put
the aim inside of it I've seen examples
of four different different than this
ways of doing long division in Latin
America in countries that border one
another and none of those countries knew
that the other country did it
differently this causes enormous
confusion as you might imagine for
students when they're asked to do it in
a different format than their teacher
knows or that anybody else knows around
them okay so that's just the basics of
making sure that your interface like
presents the right stuff going beyond
that thinking about learner autonomy and
motivation some of the key principles
for making sure that our learning
technologies work here's an example of a
study that looked at the impact of
choice on students performance and
engagement and the vast majority of the
learning sciences literature would tell
you that students kids being able to
choose what they work on is the best
thing for them right so you get to pick
which of these three problems you work
on whatever one you want and when you
choose your problem you work harder you
work longer and you end up solving those
problems faster and more accurately an
alternative to that approach is one that
asks your family to choose for you that
seems maybe a little strange to me
personally I wouldn't want my
parents picking what problems I have to
work on I'd rebelle however it turns out
that in Confucian heritage cultures this
can often be a stronger motivator to do
work and to do work more persistently
and to do work more accurately than
allowing students to have their own
personal choice so something we might
have assumed was true for everybody does
not necessarily hold for all and this is
something that's really important to
understand as we're figuring out how to
get kids to actually work on hard math
problems right and then to go even one
level beyond that I'll show you some
software that we were using in our
studies in Latin America in Costa Rica
specifically where now a lot of the
behaviors are being driven by underlying
algorithms and models things like when
and where and how to give feedback up
there on the top when and where and how
to give help from the system so there's
a lot of technology going on behind the
scenes here we are working in here in
Costa Rica on systems that hadn't been
donated by a corporation and so the
schools all have computer labs plenty of
Technology in this context as you can
see had trouble getting the kids to give
up their cell phones and so we do a lot
of work to prepare for these studies
right we have teacher meetings we do
pilot testing we work on transitioning
American versions to local versions
doing all of that hard work and then
when we're actually there we do our
evaluation by giving children a pretest
on the set of surveys we have them work
on the algebra concepts for a while in
the software and then we post-test them
to understand what they've learned from
it and along the way we collect all
sorts of different kinds of data as well
so if we just look at the pretest and
the post-test here what we find is
really good games so the US students in
the US looked like this in a very soon
our study we ran there so they went from
65 ish to almost 80% accurate on the
post-test and our Costa Rican students
almost caught up so they started out
much lower 32% on the pretest and ended
up not quite as high as the American
students but at where we are 72 or so on
the post-test so that's great we showed
that that students learned from using
this system but now we actually dive
into the system logs to see if there's
any way that we can actually make this
better they they're still the sea level
can we improve the way they do this and
one of the things that we looked at was
some of those underlying models of the
system so what's actually going on under
the hood and one of those that I
mentioned a minute ago was looking at
help-seeking right how are people
actually using the system for help when
is it providing the help are they
choosing the right times and the right
things to give for help so this is just
an example of what one of those models
might look like and visualized right
it's just sort of a flowchart think
about the step if it's familiar then you
ask for a hint otherwise if you a sense
of what to do you go this way or that
way so that's just a visualization of
what it looks like under the hood what
we do is a whole bunch of computer
science processes of working with models
where we do feature engineering
selecting the right features optimizing
to make sure that we understand which
features of help-seeking are actually
working and you come out with a list
something like this it's kind of
indecipherable but things like whether
students are avoiding help whether
they're selecting help when it's
unneeded etc etc we have a bunch of
definitions for all of these features of
the learning so not important to
actually understand the details of this
right now but what we do is evaluate
whether these models are actually
working for these learners hmm so what
we did was to look at the data from the
costa rican students and run it on the
model which had been built in the united
states right so can we actually predict
costa rican students learning from this
model that we built in the u.s turns out
that you cannot in fact as you can see
there's even an almost a slight negative
correlation between what Costa Rican
students are doing in what the model
predicts that they should be doing so
that's not good what happens if instead
we rerun the model and we combine all of
this data we put the costa rican
students data in the model too so now we
have a much bigger model should be more
accurate and we look at whether now this
can actually predict whether Costa Rican
students learn or not we cannot we
slightly better but we're still negative
so what is happening here what could be
going on in the classroom that explains
these differences in fact what we see is
that help-seeking behaviors differ in
their log data so far that no
help-seeking features from the costa
rican students actually even appeared in
the US model so the models are
completely different from one another
from the AI point of view and in fact
many of the features in the costa rican
model when in the opposite direction of
what we would have predicted they should
be from theory why is that and what can
we do to design appropriate solutions
our next questions so in order to
understand this fortunately we still had
a ton more data that we could look at
right so we we did a lot of
investigation in the mathematics
classroom before we even went into the
lab we also did lots of field
observations while students were
actually using the system and so we
could use that data maybe to explain
this so here what you see is an image of
our American students using this system
they're all very diligent sitting at
their computer working hard here are our
Costa Rican students
they're all still working hard they're
all still diligent but they're working
in a group of six right so we actually
took a look and quantified what's
happening in this classroom and what we
see we looked at where the learning
environment was taking place whether was
at the classroom the math classroom or
was at the lab where the computers were
we looked across different schools rural
and urban schools and what we find is
that the most significant difference
here is in the classroom the kids were
engaging in lots of collaborative
behavior so almost 47% of everything
they did in the classroom was
collaborative this was the biggest
difference we then looked you know
collaborative behavior is one thing but
is it actually engaged in the task is
another so we reduce this down to just
how much of their behavior is on task
collaborative behavior and even that 30
percent of what the students were doing
in the classroom was on task
collaborative behavior now you can
contrast that in the lab 14 percent of
what they were doing was on task
collaborative behavior so just the fact
of going into the lab and working on the
computers almost dropped this by half so
that's one interesting observation
already but then we asked what can we
compare this to and we have only a few
other studies out there that look at
students working with these intelligent
tutoring systems that have actually
measured their collaborative behavior
there and what we find is that in
America the average amount of on task
collaborative behavior is 4% we have a
we have another sample from the
Philippines that happens to be 9% but
critically here we've got three times
more collaboration happening compared to
us classrooms could this explain why
help-seeking models look different in
our Costa Rican data right where is
their help-seeking happening from their
friends exactly they're not asking the
system for help they're asking their
neighbor they're asking
their best friend across the room
they're asking the teacher this is why
it's not showing up in the data and why
what they are doing in on the computer
is happening in ways that that wouldn't
be predicted by theory now this is great
we've got you know students who learned
almost as much but not quite while
engaging in these behaviors they that
weren't modeled by our system but what
does that actually look like in practice
here is an example exchange you can read
that the first girl says it's 36 that's
wrong girl 2 says three-fourths girl 3
says no 3/5 good old T says no it's 3/4
I don't think so
so that's girl 1 she types in 3/4 that's
right and the third goal says huh I'm
not the end of it and they move on
all right so it is collaborative they're
all guiding ideas into this conversation
they're not doing this alone the girl
who's typing is taking suggestions from
everybody else but what we see is that
it's not transactive so this is a key
term from the collaboration literature
that says people are actually building
on each other's ideas they're taking
what was said and they're working on it
and and they're coming up with a better
solution together or even explaining
what they're doing and why so that the
other participants understand so so
again it's great that students are able
to achieve such games with software that
that doesn't work for them however could
you imagine if we build something that
actually has system supported help to
work on getting kids to explain their
answers to one another to push each
other harder are they just gonna maybe
try random answers until they get one
that's right or can we actually get them
to work together and solve these
problems in a transactive way so that's
what we're working on in building new
models along with a better system design
that actually supports these learners
where they're at and takes advantage
of that collaborative power in order to
support them better so generally what's
the outcome here for our systems as a
whole what's the principle this is to do
context-sensitive design where you
actually deeply know your context you're
there you'll observe it you understand
what's happening using learning Sciences
principles that are actually built on
students in your context and going so
far as to build our a my models actually
with learner's in the context that you
think so we're gonna add in language in
context into each of these parts of our
system diagram so my suggestion is that
we actually consider this from the very
beginning as we're planning out our
system architectures okay point number
two physical infrastructure so this is
something that I think is can be a
little rarer to think about as we're
building computer-based systems
especially if you're thinking about
building it for a screen but I'm gonna
tell you about some work happening in
the east coast of Africa in Tanzania
where the major occupations for students
in the region were goat and cattle
farming and where they had limited water
and electricity so you can see here's a
picture there there is electricity but
it's often concentrated in one place or
happens here regularly so for instance
people bring their phones to the town
centre and plug them in for a couple of
hours before they head back home because
this particular place has more
consistent access to electricity so here
we've conducted three studies in which
again we do observations we conduct
interviews and test prototypes we work
out our design guidelines build a system
we've had a year-long deployment there
we do observations over certain weeks of
it
and then we do redesigns and and observe
again what's happening sorry this is
work done my by my student Judith what
you do you know and then secondly
another study set of studies in the
ivory coast coach voix this is on the
west coast of Africa now where what they
do for a living
tends to be cocoa farming so these are
rural cocoa communities that we're
working in and there are some major
issues with literacy here so we're
working on literacy applications many
students in both of our regions where we
were working were not able to read a
single age-appropriate word so some some
real severe impacts of issues like child
labor and lack of future professional
development on what's happening in these
classrooms and again we here we have
three studies with a similar approach
here our system is called a low alphabet
and we've got six week deployments and
we're actually right in the middle of
study three right now where we've
redesigned our system we've got a four
month randomized controlled trial going
on and we'll hopefully see some good
results from that this is from my
students Michael Mateo and Vikram Cometh
so physical infrastructures what we're
talking about here one of the first
things that people do often think about
when they think about physical
infrastructure particularly in Southeast
Asia or in Africa is electricity and
this is a critical thing something that
should be absolutely considered so even
in our villages where they had
electricity we as you can see brought
along our own solar panels because you
may have times where the electricity
goes out for three or four days in a row
and you need to make sure that you're
prepared whether to support learners
with the device that you're giving them
or just to help the families out like
here's here's a access to electricity
that gives you
something that you might need so so
that's number one we bring our power
options with us and then the second
thing that we think about quite a lot is
our choice of platform or device so in
the ivory coast mobile adoption is at a
hundred and thirty percent what does
that mean there's more than one phone
per person in the country so there are a
lots of people who own multiple phones
however it turns out that the majority
of these are low cost feature phones not
smartphones or tablets and so there's a
lot of design and deployment going on
right now with smartphones because they
offer so many more features obviously
then our basic phones they have a big
screen they have the ability to show
pictures and images and movies which is
great except for despite widespread
reports that smartphones are sweeping
the continents most the vast majority of
people still only own feature phones
unless you only want to reach folks in
the urban city centers so in this case
in Ivory Coast we chose to deploy on the
phones that the parents already owned so
feature phones where they've got a small
screen and physical number keypad so
immediately that meant that we are
constrained in types in terms of the
interactions that people could use on
this phone and we also recognized the
severe lack of literacy in these
environments so the approach we chose to
take was to use almost exclusively a
voice interface so students are calling
in on what's called an interactive voice
response system where they can talk into
the phone they can get responses back
and the phone can recognize and adapt to
their answers we combine that with an
SMS approach so that as they progress
through the literacy curriculum they can
start looking at
the orthography or the spelling and way
that letters look on the screen so this
is a choice we made that limited the
types of things we were able to do but
it was a choice that we made in order to
make sure that the families could
actually work with this software on the
other hand in Tanzania we were
constrained by the funders and the other
constituents and stakeholders in this
environment and so we had a requirement
that we had to use tablets what we found
in our deployments despite the fact that
there's again widespread reports that
all you have to do is introduce a tablet
to a kid and they are immediately able
to start using it
maybe you've seen this if with
two-year-olds on the internet where they
just start swiping and you know
everything is no problem one of the
reasons for this in an environment like
Stanford is because they've been
watching their parents do it for two
years what we found in our case was that
only two children out of a hundred and
ninety-eight that we observed were able
to tap correctly without help often even
after we left them alone for an hour or
two hours with the device so we have to
keep in mind that training is needed if
we're going to actually conceive of this
as an appropriate support tool some
other interesting things that we found
in physical infrastructure needs were
data transport so we expect to just be
able to deliver our data to connect to
the network to to provide updates to
write solutions to collect students data
and in many cases we actually turned out
having to employ motorcycle drivers
boda-bodas their code to deliver a USB
keys with updates to our software in
order for them to get to the learners in
a timely fashion
beyond that we actually
works with a type of job that's not seen
too frequently in the US anymore called
a griot this is somebody who the closest
English word is like a town crier right
they actually go out and they tell the
news maybe they tell stories or they
keep the oral history but this is the
way to get updates out into the
community when you don't have a
technological solution right so we paid
somebody to provide updates on for
instance when the study was starting or
we found a bug with the system that
people were not able to continue using
it and that we had to pay somebody to go
out and spread the word physically that
this was the way the system was going to
be working now so for physical
infrastructure we found that you really
need to pay attention to three things
the devices the interface and the
modality and all of the communication
that happens around such systems and
once again we think actually adding the
physical infrastructure into your system
architecture is the only way to make
sure that these features are actually
considered whether it's a motorcycle or
some other way of actually delivering
the approach that you need to get
updates or data in and out of your
system the really critical piece of this
is that last mile right so if you've
heard of this this is a problem in
transportation in general you have bus
systems or train systems that can get
people everywhere but then what happens
when they get off of that train they
need transportation to get to that that
last little bit of the end point so all
of our systems worked very well we could
test them in-house people could use them
in the context but it's getting that
last step of getting them to actually be
able to use it in the field
that requires that extra physical
infrastructure that we hadn't put in
place in the first part and then finally
gonna talk a little bit about human
infrastructure so physical
infrastructure
sort of
started to bleed into this right we
needed a motorcycle driver we needed a
town crier to actually go out and tell
people about our studies and what was
happening but there's a lot of other
physical human infrastructure that needs
to be involved in the deployment of
these software systems as well the first
one I'll mention is Pierce of course I
talked about that in our Costa Rican
data right there were children helping
one another there's a lot of
collaboration going on thinking about
peers is a really important part of
building any educational system and in
particular in the ivory coast we had
parents who said this was really
important to them all my children must
be at the same level
there's none who can be above the others
if I have five children and I show
something to one the others must also
understand that thing right so really
critical that kids are all working
together however in our work in Tanzania
we actually experimentally deployed an
approach in which sorry and title of
this slide is wrong the three points
here where are three conditions we had
no leader assigned so the kids were just
able to work as they desired
we had a privately assigned and trained
leader so we took one kid aside said hey
you're gonna be the helper for this
group here's how you do it and let them
go and then in the third case we told
everybody in the group hey this child is
the leader they're going to help you
when you need help make sure to ask if
you need help and that child was trained
on how to support them so what did we
find we found that in this context peers
only provided help to one another when
all of the following conditions were
true they had to notice a peer
struggling or the peer had to directly
ask for help and then the peer had to
only be one of those that was adjacent
to them they were also required to not
be so in depth in their own enjoyment of
the
game that they were playing that they
wanted to take a step back and help
their other Peter and then it only
happened in cases where they already
knew what the answer was so I've seen
that problem before I'll help you click
here if they had to stop and consider
how to support them with a new solution
that help didn't happen a lot of the
work that happens in these contexts
assumes that peer leaders will naturally
emerge so you know we'd give a bunch of
tablets to a bunch of students one of
them's gonna figure it out and they're
gonna tell all of the others so we don't
have to worry about actually building
this support in to the system well in
our observations we found that children
even when they were naturally sort of
helpers in the classroom they did not do
this sort of help when they got out into
the field with the system in fact they
ignored an average of 79 percent of all
help requests this doesn't mean however
that they never helped each other they
provided the best help when two things
were true they were trained so not the
one where we not in the condition where
we didn't train anyone and we just
assumed that leaders might emerge so
they had to be trained and there was a
social expectation of them providing
support so the publicly assigned leader
condition so everyone else was told this
is the person you go to for help so this
gives us some indications of how we
might actually build support into the
system for these things to happen right
you can publicly designate a leader in
the system you can tell people to go ask
you can support these leaders with
training when needed all right
we're uh we're coming towards the end of
class so I want to make sure to give a
chance for a question so I'm gonna go
through this a little bit more quickly
teachers are some group of people that
are also often neglected in this space
with the idea that maybe teachers
actually get in the way so what did we
find when we looked at how teachers
actually supported these
students we found that teachers provided
three things three types of support
one was application support so here's
how you get into this game here's how
you go to this other game the second was
knowledge support so here's actually how
this math concept works or here's how
you read this word and then the third
was digital literacy support so again
kids had a lot of trouble working on
tablets by themselves teachers were
there to help them another thing that
they provided outside of these direct
forms of support were a motivation to
persist so in the school environment
students were diligently working we went
to home environments and watch children
use these here as well a little blurry
but you can see this kid is just gotten
totally exhausted
throws himself down on the couch and has
completely given up for the day he can't
figure out how to do this next thing so
he's done with it
teachers really provided that support
for persistence that that motivation to
continue what they did not provide on
the other hand was support for
exploration
so in our school environment the
students were very directed the teachers
even one unprompted would come tell them
what to do this is where you should go
next here's how to proceed whereas in
the home environment this is where we
saw others who were not involved in the
study come over ask what this thing was
about how what happens if you click over
here and so they ended up seeing a much
wider set of content and trying a much
wider set of things that were available
in the software than they ever did in
the schools all right I'm gonna skip
through this bit a little bit but one of
the interesting things that we saw was
that sometimes parents didn't
necessarily have much trust in the
system the education system in cote
ivoire has changed so much that the
children must have tutors because
without the tutors I am sure
cannot make it out of the system so they
paid the what very tiny tiny amounts of
money they had left over at the end of
the month to actually have somebody come
into their home or get a group of
students and basically have like a
second school day after the end of
school and so this is sort of what that
looked like
you know they might have a blackboard at
home to support this and we have a tutor
who would help them provide the support
at home and sometimes this was because
the teachers themselves did not have the
domain knowledge and so they were not
able to support the children on that so
you know many of our parents despite
being extremely low-income valued
education to the extent that they paid
for materials at home and for home
tutors as well now moving into the idea
of parents and adult supporters well it
turns out that they're pretty
foundational we know this from a lot of
studies around the world in terms of
providing an environment in which
literacy can thrive you may have seen
some of the studies that show that
high-income children in the United
States are exposed to about a million
more words than low-income children in
the United States and so a lot of this
literacy early work in literacy even
before you get to writing is happening
at home so we wanted to understand how
parents and other adults supporters
might actually provide an environment
for these sorts of software systems to
thrive so some of the things that we
found were that only 12 out of 38 of our
participants in study two reported
having a parent who was literate so the
parents themselves may not know how to
read or write and we believe this was an
over reporting so they're reporting a
parent who can read or write again that
may be a second grade level so there's
very little actual school-based literacy
support that they can get from their
parents however the things that parents
were able to provide were
again digital literacy so they are
actually able to make a phone call for
the kids and get them on to it they're
able to find the right number in the
contact list they're able to interpret
between what's happening on the phone
and what the kids actually need to do so
this is important because in some other
environments around the world what we
find is that children are actually the
ones that help the adults with digital
literacy so they pick something up and
then you know they show that new thing
to their parents in these sorts of
environments for the vast majority of
cases it's the other way around one of
the reasons for that is because adults
and parents are in control of the
technology and the children only are
allowed to use technology when their
parents give them permission the next
thing that they do is communicate the
value of literacy to their children so
they can say I can send my child out
into the world without worrying knowing
that my child knows how to write if I
see that they're planning to go out
alone to the child nearby I can write a
little something so they give their
child tasks or they tell the child pay
attention to everything you learn at
school because that is what will allow
you to move ahead or if you do not study
and if for example I die and leave you
all alone what are you going to eat
really strong motivation for their
children to pay attention in just in
school and to learn how to read so we
actually in the end after study 2
developed an adult literacy support tool
that helps them do a number of things
including learn why this work is
important support them in helping and
motivating their children so encouraging
them to give this advice that they're
giving to the children to help motivate
them to continue and finally to actually
maybe learn some of the content
themselves so under the guise of here's
how you could help your child we gave
them similar exercises as their children
and then if they so desired they could
also pick up some of these literacy
concepts so I'm gonna go give you just a
preliminary look at this we're still as
I said just in the middle of this larger
scale study but what we find is that
students with parental support
answer 10% more questions correctly in
the system even when the parents
themselves are not literate so the
parents aren't giving them the answers
and in fact one of our participants said
it's not like I know anything about it
but since the tutor is not there what
you know at school what you've been
shown there you have to do in front of
me right so they're motivating them to
do this even when they don't know what
the answers are interestingly to explain
this we saw no effect of children's
pretest performance on their correctness
so I mean everybody was pretty low to
begin with but it didn't quite matter
what you knew before what did matter was
the number of calls the user made to the
system and that impacted correctness the
children's ability to answer so we think
what's happening is the children with
parental support are getting encouraged
to call more often and they're working
harder on these questions and they're
getting more of those questions correct
all right so the sum here is to say one
way or another everyone in the house
brings their grain of salt and
reinforcing the education of the child
which brings us to the conclusion of our
human infrastructure where we actually
want you to build these supports into
the system into the architecture diagram
from the beginning and not just sort of
rely on that they might happen when they
get out there in the real world okay so
in sum I've talked about three main
principles context-sensitive design
physical infrastructure and human
infrastructure these are the three
things that we believe need to be
physically added in to your system and
thought about from the very beginning
and there are lots and lots of people
who have contributed this work so I'd
like to give a big thank you to
everybody and thank you to everybody
here for being so patient and attentive
with me I hope you've learned something
interesting today
you